♪♪
-Someone said a very nice
thing to me recently.
They say that whenever they hear
the word "corrections,"
the first thing they think
about is this segment.
You know who said that?
Jonathan Franzen.
[ Laughter ]
[ Soft music plays ]
Brian Lodato
won the Thanksgiving
Corrections pool where the money
goes to whoever
has the box that lines up
with the minutes and seconds.
I've been told by not just him
but other members of the crew
Kenny really needs this one.
[ Laughter ]
The San Diego Zoo no longer
has giant pandas.
They have red pandas now.
Do you know how you go
from giant pandas to red pandas?
Ozempic.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
We do a segment called
"Surprise Inspection."
I read bad jokes
our writers have written.
And then I show their picture
to shame them.
Well, I was gobsmacked...
[ Laughter ]
...this week when I called
for Matt Goldich's picture,
expecting this.
The established Matt Goldich
surprise inspection photo
and instead
was greeted with this.
[ Laughter ]
It doesn't work with this.
This.
This guy writes jokes
like "Pepsi has announced
it will no longer
offer Sierra Mist soda.
Oh, no. Then how will I make
my famous Sierra Mist stew
[tiramisu]?"
This guy writes that.
This guy writes
grunge rock anthems.
Pull a surprise inspection
on this guy,
he flicks a lit cigarette
in your face.
And since when
are our writers allowed
to update their own headshots?
[ Laughter ]
Since when?
I blame Lloyd.
[ Laughter ]
Our photographer.
The next time he asks,
Lloyd, I invite you to say,
[Scottish accent]
"I cannae do it!"
[ Laughter ]
I don't have the authority,
wee Matt!
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] They don't fill
them that high at bars.
Also in "Surprise Inspection,"
Bryan Donaldson had a joke
about chlamydia.
The joke was "the FDA last week
authorized the first
at-home STD test for chlamydia.
So give the FDA
a big round of clap."
Many of you pointed out clap
is slang for gonorrhea,
and Bryan wanted me to tell you
he definitely knows that.
He can't go into why,
but he knows that.
[ Two notes play ]
Chlamydia got its name from
the Greek word chlamydia,
which means "cloak."
I mean, honest. What would be
a bigger red flag on a date?
If they had chlamydia
or if they showed up
to the restaurant in a cloak?
[ Laughter ]
I'm happy to announce.
Think you've noticed,
but I'll announce it anyway.
"Closer Look" videos are once
again available in Canada
and to our Canadian viewers.
I'd just like to say
I hope you learned your lesson.
[ Laughter ]
You know what you did.
I'm so glad
we got this cleared up.
The comments about this.
You know,
despite their reputation
for politeness,
Canadian people have been
so snippy about this.
Like it was a personal choice
that I made.
Somebody said,
"Oh, now you won't
show us 'Closer Looks,'
you jerk?"
Like this was up to me.
Like once a week
NBC comes in and checks
which countries I'm okay
with the "Closer Looks"
being available to watch.
Like somebody
walked in and said,
"Are you still good with
Canada?" And I'm like, "No."
[ Laughter ]
"I've tired of Canada.
Remove it.
Let them watch Kimmel."
I did an impression
of Werner Herzog as Shaggy
singing the lyrics
to the infidelity classic
"It Wasn't Me."
Many of you
Pointed out that I was not doing
Shaggy's lines from that song.
I was doing the lines
from the other half of that song
that were sung by Rik Rok.
Shaggy's role in the song
is giver of advice.
The core of that advice
you could
boil down to say "it wasn't me."
Rik Rok -- If you watched the
video, which I highly recommend,
Rik Rok goes to his home
to receive this advice.
I do want to apologize
for the Rik Rok
erasure, though,
in the bit that I did last week.
He's great in the song.
You know who I always get
Rik Rok confused with?
Rick...
♪♪
I love Shaggy, but Rik Rok
does most of the work
in that song.
It's funny that Shaggy
called him up and said,
"I've got a great song."
You guys remember
how Shaggy talks, right?
So just imagine him
talking like that while I talk.
[ Laughter ]
"Hey, Rik Rok, got
a great new song I want you on."
"Cool. What's it about?"
"It's about a dude
who def gets cheating --
gets caught cheating because
he's dumb as a box of rocks."
"Okay, cool. And what do I do?"
"No, that's you, Rik Rok.
I'm gonna be in the video.
I'm going to be wearing
the most kickass purple suit."
Rik Rok was like, "Oh,
do I get to wear a purple suit?"
He's like, "Red turtleneck."
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
This was sent to me.
I want to establish.
It was not a prop I asked
Ellen for.
This came in the mail.
This is one is awkward.
Many of you included
the timestamp.
So I became concerned
because everybody had
the same timestamp,
accused me of passing gas
in last week's "Correction"...
[ Laughter ]
...and then tried to get away
with it like nothing happened.
I went back and listened.
It's the chair.
It is 100%
the sound of the chair.
And like, ha ha, I get it.
Flatulence is funny,
but false accusations are not.
[ Laughter ]
I'm going to prove it.
I'm going to play it.
So listen.
And by the way, really listen
because you can even
barely hear it.
Roll it, Alex.
It's Thanksgiving,
not April Fool's, Baze.
[ Loud fart sound ]
Um...
[ Laughter ]
It was lowbrow.
It's a lowbrow joke,
but I feel like, you know,
I feel like I earned it
with that Franzen ref.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Here are some comments
from this week.
I like
to isolate certain comments
that really stick with me.
"Hey, Seth, I never really
enjoyed you
on 'SNL' or anything, really."
[ Laughter ]
"But for some reason,
'Closer Look'
and 'Corrections' work on me."
You know, right next
to impressions camp,
they have a compliment camp.
[ Laughter ]
Check it out next summer.
My family was on
the Thanksgiving show.
Delight.
Best I feel they ever did.
Loved it.
It was nice.
It's nice to read comments
when people at home
also enjoy them
as much as I did.
Here's one.
"Seth's brother is so good.
It's like if Seth was funny
and had charisma."
[ Laughter ]
But comment of the week.
This is 88, by the way.
Last week, 87th episode
of "Corrections."
"I've watched all of these
and it still doesn't work."
[ Laughter ]
Talked about my kids
and their middle names.
My oldest's first and
middle name are Ashe Olson.
Ashe Olson.
Not, as one of you said, [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
We'll say this.
Hard to unhear it.
[ Laughter ]
"Bad news, honey.
The jackals noticed
something about Ashe's name."
"Who are the jackals?"
[ Laughter ]
"You know, from Emmy-nominated
'Corrections.'"
[ Laughter ]
"Honey, I can hear you
blinking."
[ Laughter ]
I also -- We had a great, uh,
great Thanksgiving show,
and then right after it...
...recorded a Thanksgiving
"Corrections."
It was really a good one.
I think a lot of you agreed.
Someone even wrote "the crew
must be extra drunk
because they're really
laughing this week."
Or was it funny?
[ Laughter ]
I do do this for a living,
you know?
Doesn't have to be
a chemical reason it played.
I do a lot of work
on "Corrections."
You know what
the hardest part is?
Loading the comments.
Believe it or not,
that's the hardest part.
Sometimes these things
have like 3,000 comments.
You just gotta, like,
keep scrolling down.
[ Sighs ]
Someone said that
they could tell
the can of Slice I used
last week wasn't full.
No [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
Think I'm gonna let someone
ship me a full can of Slice,
a soda
they discontinued in 2005.
You think that's safe?
Yeah.
I'll take a full can of Slice,
some nitro, and some glycerin.
Same box.
♪♪
Also, you know what?
I was told I purse my lips weird
before taking sips of my drink.
[ Laughter ]
Is -- It's normal.
Watch this, Shoemaker.
Tell me if it's not normal.
Alex?
[ Loud fart sound ]
See me next two weeks.
[ Laughter ]
[ Two notes play ]
Scooby-Doo is not an Anunnaki
as I said.
He's a descendant
of an Anunnaki
like all talking animals
in that universe.
That was one of 50 comments
clarifying this.
Here's another one.
"Point of order --
Scooby is descended from a dog
who was possessed by a Anunnaki,
not a descendant
from an actual Anunnaki.
Through whatever
magical process,
the original dog's
physiological -- physiological,"
excuse me -- "attributes
were permanently changed,
and those traits
continued down its lineage.
The Scooby-Doo Anunnaki plot was
part of 'Mystery Incorporated,'
which is one of the most popular
and well-liked Scooby series."
I was also told Scooby-Doo
says "ruh-roh," but the Anunnaki
pronounces it differently.
Let's take a look.
-Oh! Rickroll.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Misplayed my closer.
Almost out of time.
Crew eagerly
checking their watches.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Will this be?
Will this be the week
for a certain someone?
♪♪
Again, want to stress something.
Didn't make this.
[ Laughter ]
Just came to the P.O. box.
P.O. box.
Kind of wish I hadn't looked.
I did though.
Couldn't believe it.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Laughter continues ]
You know, every now
and then I remember
why I keep you jackals around.
[ Laughter ]
See me next week.